[Music]
Are you kidding? This is the second stage. I'm
sorry, I'm not kidding.
Woody, how fast are you moving? Help me, but wait,
Navarre is still here.
[Music]
Stop the di magic. The
loin that Navarre used is
In exchange for giving me power that exceeds my limits, I feed on the life of the messenger. It seems that
life is no longer possible. Let me
pursue the hero,
but I can't let him live. I haven't given it my all yet. I
kill the enemy and the battlefield is the only place I belong.  I had no
choice but to scatter into nothingness on the battlefield.
I, Navarre Polar,
decided where I would die and found the will to die, and above all, the memory of my friend.  It's such a
sunny day that it's a waste for a sword demon who can stay behind.